sorti sur nos écrans ce mercredi deux
oiseaux world d'un film américain qui a
coûté la bagatelle d'un milliard de
francs budget record dans l'histoire du
cinéma
folle de kevin cosner nicole peur d'une
langlois a chaussé ses palmes pour voir
ce mad max des mères
en 2005 sans la mer a recouvert notre
planète
les hommes se recoupent sur des atolls
artificiels et recherche le mythique dry
land la terre ferme comme autrefois
arrive un navigateur solitaire marine
air il a les pieds palmés et des
branchies dans les lobes d'oreilles
il ne lui manque que des nageoires pour
être coincés dans la ville kevin costner
et moins fier disons plus abordable et
c'est défendre ce un film contre vents
et marées c'est même du héros de cinéma
souvent ne sais pas d'où vient ce guide
de baroudeur noël avec un fort mais je
crois qu'au cinéma
les héros sont complexes un meilleur ils
sont celui ci est particulièrement dur
dans ses rapports avec les femmes les
enfants ni les autres
être solitaire marine heures danses avec
les vagues ne ménage pas les femmes qui
l'accompagnent à bord de son trimaran
pour elle c'est difficile à vivre
surtout pas voir le mal de mer au large
d'hawaï 3 il ya d'énormes vagues qui
font tanguer le bateau comme ça pas du
tout agréable
parmi les survivants se trouvent des
méchants qui poursuivent la petite fille
car sur son dos est tatoué le plan de la
terre promise ne se déplace en scooter
et polluent l'atmosphère
le chef s'est dit comme ça mais
malheureusement un peu plus sa part de
nos industriels leur attitude consiste à
prendre prendre prendre et prendre ce
que donne la terre sans jamais rien
restitués et puis mourir c'est sa neex
voilà rassurés le film le plus cher du
monde a donc un message écologique
ces explosions s'est constitué et
acculèrent ont un sens kevin costner ne
joue pas seulement le héros hollywoodien
invincible il nous prévient avec celui
ci prenons pas garde et waterworld
d'arrivée